Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
Today it's September
9th, 2021 for Gueststream
number 10.1 double digits
or double digits for the decimal.
And we're really honored and appreciative
to have Professor Philip Gerrans today
coming in from Austrialia, and also Dave
joining us on stream.
We're going to have
a presentation from Philip
and then we're going to have some time
for discussion and dialog.
So if you're watching live,
please feel free to leave questions
in the live chat
and we will address those on the stream
and we're just really looking forward
to this.
And again, appreciative
that you're coming on our stream.
So thanks and take it away.
Philip.
Okay, great.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much for the invitation.
I spoke to Anna Ciaunica, who told me
that she had a great experience
with you guys.
So I'm very, very happy to be able to
present and
to tell you a little bit
about the background to this talk.
I was originally a philosopher of mind
and of cognitive science,
and I'm very interested in the
use of of models and techniques
in cognitive science
to understand psychiatric disorder.
And I found predictive processing
very helpful when I was writing a book
on this a few years ago.
But looking back at
some other psychiatric disorders
like the Cotard Delusion and so on,
I think it's really great to kind of go
a little bit deeper and more,
more fundamental.
If you think of predictive processing
as kind of like a computational structure
at the level of representation
of an algorithm,
but of course
a lot of psychiatric disorders.
I think we've got a very bottom
up genesis.
We really need to know about how
the brain is working to control the body
and even how the body is working
in its social world.
So the active inference framework for me
has been very helpful
in rethinking this in this book
that I'm writing right now.
And also, I think it's it's
actually crucial to understanding
a phenomenon that I'm talking about
right now that the Cotard delusion.
Cotard delusion is so interesting
because.
Well, it's interesting in itself,
as you'll see.
It's fascinating phenomenon, but
it points us to some really interesting,
interesting facts or
interesting evidence
about the way the mind is.
Mind is working at a really basic level
and how that remedies
and cascades upwards
throughout cognition and behavior.
So let's go I'll just tell you
what the cocktail delusion is.
It's the delusion of sometimes
people think of it in the folk world
as the delusion that you're dead.
I was discovered in 1882,
as usual cutoff, but
we described it more accurately,
I think, as the delusion of in existence.
So here is someone who has a
she had the experience of having
no identity or self
and being only a body with that content.
She convinced it her brain to disappeared
and the whole body was translucent.
Another one more recent one.
I speak and breathe
and eat, but I'm dead.
Okay, so this classic
examples, but here is a really recent one
published in the last couple of years.
This is fascinating cases
coming from Mexico.
There's a really good group there
that works on this.
So Mr.
A was referred
to the National Institute of Neurology.
Because of psychotic and catatonic
symptoms, his appetite diminished.
He barely slept.
He stayed withdrawn and silent
and complained that his body sitting,
his tendons dried up
and his organs were getting bigger.
Speak of an internal hemorrhage.
His organs have been torn apart
and he began to insist that he was dead.
I can't feel the blood flowing
through my veins.
Didn't
deprive him of looking for sharp objects
to cut his neck and forearms.
Then he gradually improved.
Or first he became mute, began to urinate
on his clothes, refused to eat, and
then speak.
Finally, you know, after some treatment,
he said he's improved slightly,
but he said,
I don't have feelings because I'm dead.
He had a right sided heart
and that had stopped.
And then he kept on saying,
even after persisting treatment is near
holistic delusions,
as they're accurately called,
you know, delusions
of in existence of nothingness.
I am data among other human beings.
It's like a program where I'm dead.
And he said, who is a dead person
among the corpses under the earthquake,
debris? Now,
the genesis of this case of Cotard
delusion is
encephalitis, a form of encephalitis,
which an autoimmune reaction
against proteins in the brain.
So it's one of the most basic things
that can go wrong at the cellular level.
And if the protein is in methods
per type, the condition is called
NMDA antibody encephalitis. Okay.
So that's what. Mr.. Ahead.
But of course,
our interesting question is
if we know what's happening
at the molecular level, at the level
of kind of membranes and receptors,
why on earth would that make
you think that it didn't exist?
So they were address
that they were in the
in the field of addressing the question,
you know,
how does the brain
enable experience and cognition?
That's that's the questions
of cognitive neuroscience
and psychology
and anyone else who wants to get involved
in that topic, phenomenology, philosophy.
Okay.
But it's a really pertinent question.
So here's the outline of the talk.
I just told you about the delusion,
and then I'm going to tell you about
some of the classic attempts
to explain it.
Just run through those
and point to a problem with those.
And then in discussing
one of the most recent
and persuasive
and really interesting explanations
that we owe to Alexandre Billon,
I'm going to introduce
the active inference approach,
and I'm going to show how the active
inference approach can rectify a problem
we saw beyond the account,
but also point to point to some other
deep sort of unifying themes
across
cognitive science and across disorders.
So the active inference framework,
I think it's an elegant
and persuasive
way to explain not just cases like Mr.
AI, but a lot of other
these other disorders
and pathologies
where our experience of our self
goes astray.
So things like pain, Somalia,
where people say that
they experiencing pain, but also
that their body is experiencing pain,
but it's not happening to them.
But it feels as though
it's not their pain or depersonalization
disorders in which people will say
not just that pain, it's not theirs,
but they feel it outside of a detach
from their whole experience.
Okay, so
and the solution that I'll propose,
I'll give you the short
summary right now is that as part of the
project or
process of active inference, the body,
the brain makes hierarchical
models of itself and the world of deep
the deep structure of the world
as is populated with objects
and properties that the external world
with which it interacts.
But of course the brain
also has to make a model of its own
internal
functioning.
The processes that that keep
it keep us alive and functioning.
And in order to do that,
it makes a model of itself
as a unified, persisting entity.
And that's what we feel the self.
That's what we feel when we feel like,
like persisting people,
when we feel like a self,
we are the model.
That's what we've, we're
experiencing activity in the circuitry
that makes that self model okay.
And in a cotard
delusion this, the self model
goes wrong
in a certain way or that process of self
modeling goes wrong in a certain way.
But we can see other disorders in which
that process of self modeling goes wrong.
And I think that theory makes it maps
really nicely
to the the neural substrates
of all these disorders.
It explains the symptoms and so on.
So let's go.
So of course, as we saw,
it's such an interesting disorder,
the Cotard delusion, because,
you know, there's
there's questions in sort of philosophy
and about rational belief fixation.
And so,
I mean, how could someone coherently say
I've died or I don't exist?
And there's a question about rationality
there and the nature of reasoning
and so on, on the basis of experience,
which is interesting in itself,
which is that's part of
the philosophy of delusions, I guess, or
the philosophy of psychiatric disorder,
where I came into this topic a while ago.
But of course, it's
also very interesting in
how can you also have
the experience of not existing, you know,
so it points us to the question
of what is going on
when you actually feel like a self, okay?
And of course, it's also
a great test case for theories that try
and explain experience and cognition
in terms of underlying
neural functioning.
So here's the kind of broad brush
of the kind of classic approaches
to these topics
that you get in a series of delusions.
And so I guess it's the early nineties
which tried to weight
philosophy of belief,
rational belief, fixation
to the neuroscience
of delusion formation, and that the most
top level abstract by putting it is
there's two stages in delusion formation.
The first one is an unusual
or anomalous, as they say, sensory
experience.
So it's something goes wrong
at the level of sensory motor functioning
gives you an unusual experience.
And then the second stage is
a metacognitive response
to that experience.
And so this is why someone, for example,
who lost control
or is unable to feel,
unable to feel
that they are the agent of their actions
when they're picking up things
and moving around the world.
Okay.
That's the loss of,
as they call, sense of agency due to
normally problems in the
parietal lobe,
your inferior parietal lobe,
something goes wrong there
with the kind of sensory motor
and action of agency.
And then the people person will say
to explain that we had experience
of moving around the world
but not feeling like they are the person
who initiated the movement
or controlling it.
Let's say someone else is controlling me
in that said delusions of control
as that state.
That would be a classic case.
We have an anomalous experience
at the first stage
and then the delusion is a belief
or some kind of cognitive rationalization
or story that the person tells.
Okay, now there's two implications of the
the two stage theory.
One is that, well,
if the patient doesn't have
a problem
with higher order processing,
then she won't develop a delusion
because the delusion
is a medical response, right?
So in that case, the person should have
an anomalous experience.
She should feel like
she's making movements that aren't hers.
For example.
Or you might feel like you're
hearing voice, you feel like you're
hearing voices,
and the person will just report that
having an unusual,
weird, distressing experience.
But they wouldn't
go on to have a delusion
because the delusion is the result
of a problem at this stage of
they cycle belief
fixation or metacognition.
Okay.
And if this is really right, then
there should be cases in which people
have the unusual experience,
but they don't go on to have a delusion.
And of course, we are all familiar
with this in everyday life.
If you think about it,
you've probably
had feelings of deja vu or Gemini vu,
you know, in déja vu.
You think I've been here before,
I've had this experience before,
even though you know that you haven't.
And this is the point that, you know,
you can have an experience
that is completely anomalous or weird,
then go on to have a delusion about it.
But in this case you say, Well,
it feels as if I've been here before,
or in the opposite case,
my view, you know,
you walk into your bedroom
and it feels like you sleep every night.
You just have this fleeting instant of
what this is new.
This feels like a duplicate
of my bedroom or something.
But you don't go on to form a delusion
because rational insight is retained.
Unlike the classic case of delusions
of misidentification, which I spend
my time on
in a delusion,
a miss, a misidentification
person will say something like
They'll see their wife
or see their husband
or a boyfriend or something
and say that they're a stranger.
Say and you say.
Why do you say that?
They look the same as their appearance
and then they look identical.
But they are like a replica or duplicate
or an imposter in the classic delusion.
And the story is what has gone wrong here
is there's a problem
at the level of sensory processing.
So the thought is that normally
when we see a familiar face,
we get an effective response
to that face,
which is part of a signal that that's
a familiar person I see you see my sister
or my partner, and then it's like,
oh yeah, that's that's her.
So it's a feeling of familiarity
that's based in fact.
But when that goes missing, then all the
other perceptual information is intact.
I recognize the face,
the shape of the face and so on.
But I don't they don't feel familiar.
And in the case of delusions
of misidentification,
the person rationalizes
these losses or alterations to the sense
of familiarity by saying, oh, you know,
my wife's been replaced with an impostor.
Amazing delusions, but there you go.
But that's just an example
of the kind of two stage
theory of delusion formation,
which was developed for delusions of
misidentification.
Now, in turning to the Cotard delusion,
what is the first stage
in this framework?
Well, Alexandre Billon
says that it's the loss
of what people call
the sense of mind illness
or a subjective presence
is what Neil Smith calls
this and people from Sussex
who work on defense notation.
The basic idea is that
something that philosophers
and many people have remarked on or
thought about
is that when you have experiences,
part of that experience is an awareness
that you are the person
who's having experience,
as your spouse said,
every psychic manifestation,
perception, bodily memory,
it carries with it
this feeling of being mind,
having an online quality
of personally belonging.
It's been termed personalization.
And so the thought is,
just as when you see familiar people,
there's this kind of subtle,
just a subtle, subtle
feeling of familiarity,
which you don't even notice
that it's there until it goes missing.
And so it's the case
that with your everyday experience,
it feels like it's yours.
I mean, who else?
So there's this kind of aspect
of subjectivity or subjective presence
that you wouldn't even become aware of
until it went missing.
We only see it as we only even notice
that this is an experience,
a kind of a subtle accompaniment
to all of life until
we are confronted with experiences
exceptional in pathological cases,
and then if it goes missing, it
really in trouble.
So for example,
in the case of pain, a symbolic
what can happen is that someone can have
a pain
that can have the experience of pain
and they can report that experience
of pain saying, yeah, you know,
I mean, yeah, I'm in pain,
but it doesn't feel like it's my pain.
Know, detach
like it's not happening to me.
It's not interrogation, you say,
Yeah, yeah, you know, it feels hot.
I feel kind of pressure.
It feels intense.
In other words,
they can be still able to detect
and represent bodily damage
through the process of, as it's called,
you know, deception, the primary
representation of pain stimuli.
Okay.
But something else has gone
missing, involved in this knots.
And there's two theories about pain,
symbolism.
One is that what's gone
missing is an emotional response to pain.
So that would be the thought that
in the normal case of pain,
you have no deception.
You know that detection
and representation of bodily damage.
And then there's,
if you like, an effective
or an emotional response
or interpretation to that
and the resultant pain experience
is like a merger
or a combination bodily damage, plus
the stress.
And that's what you report.
But when you take the distress
part out, you just get the representation
of bodily damage.
That's one theory of pain.
But Collin Klein had a different account.
Now Colin finds you.
It's not a loss of affect.
This is not the loss of effect.
It's a loss of the sense of minus.
So a symbolic on his view
is a localized version
of depersonalization experience.
A symbolic is if like a restricted case,
just just to the pain processing
where the connection between
the processing of bodily damage,
most deception, as it's called,
and it's subtle feeling that the
experience belongs to you, comes apart.
So as he says, this
sort of unity may fail.
Okay.
And this leads to what he calls
depersonalization or pain,
as opposed to depersonalization
in the general case,
where the loss of the sense of minus
is not just for pain,
but for everything.
So someone with severe personalization
disorder
will move through life,
you know, having sensations,
sensations of movement, you know,
perceptual sensations,
bodily experiences,
but feeling as if those things
don't belong to them.
As someone says,
he it feels almost like I have died,
but no one's thought to tell me.
So I'm living in a shell
that I don't recognize.
I felt my brain was somewhere else
and just watching me, I couldn't
tell whether I was present or whether
I was the part that it was gone.
There was the one watching and the other.
It's like seeing life as if it were
played in a film or a movie.
But in that case,
who is watching the film?
I find myself regaining existence.
And so from beyond the tomb,
I'm outside my own body
and individuality, I'm depersonalized.
So just to recap, Guy
Klein gives us the idea that in a pain
symbolic, you lose the sense of minus
or belonging to me
for one particular channel of bodily
processing that some notes, etc.
and what pain signaling.
But in depersonalization,
this loss is global.
And when the loss is global, the person
reports depersonalization for everything
and the feeling there is like, well,
they say it feels as if I don't exist.
It feels like I'm not there. Right.
And so how should we explain
what's going on here?
Well, it's different theories
Billon has one
I had 120 years ago spit out of date
now I think I'm updating it today
even as we speak.
And then we have the one
I will be talking about today, which
we owe to the active inference
guys like Seth's accused so
but his
Beyonce
take on it which is very interestingly
so don't know
what Beyonce is
is that depersonalization?
Is this case of an anomalous experience
and the anomalous or strange experience
is the feeling that the self is unreal
and it's not there.
And so if we go back to the Cotard
delusion, remember
the two stage theory of delusion
is that a delusion arises
when you have an anomalous experience
and then you have some problem
at a higher level
of rational interpretation, narrative
organization or metacognition,
so that you,
you have no rational insight
into the experience
or are unable to explain it, for
you end up just taking it for granted.
And that's beyond the idea
about depersonalization.
It's the first stage of Cotard delusion.
So it's
when someone with depersonalization says
it feels as if I don't exist.
It feels as if I'm not here.
It feels as if experience is outside
me or I'm not involved in it.
That's because they're having
the same experience as the Cotard person
the Catalan patient has,
but they have rational insight,
an intact metacognition.
So they can look
they can look at that experience and say
it feels as if I don't exist.
It feels as if experience isn't mine.
But I know that's not true.
So I report it
just saying it feels that way.
But I don't.
They don't develop the delusion.
So what differentiates Cotard
and depersonalized delusions
is that the Cotard
patient has the same experience as as a
as a patient with depersonalization,
but they have intact, rational insight.
Okay, now that's the philosophical angle.
But recently, this very interesting
group of guys in Mexico
have a neuropsychiatric version
of Alexandra Beyonce to stage a count,
which is they explain Mr.
A's case.
You know, the man who thought that his organs have dried up and that he was dead,
he has insular cortex dysfunction.
And that insular cortex
dysfunction is the first factor.
Okay.
So the insular cortex
dysfunction produces
the experience
of depersonalization,
the feeling that that one sensory
experiences and cognitions that belong
to to the subject or that.
And then there's a prefrontal cortex
dysfunction
that produces a second
for the second factor.
So this is the story.
Look on the left,
you've got the the first stage
insular cortex produces
this anomalous, subjecting feeling state.
So you have hyperactive insular cortex
or maybe lesion or
neurochemical disruption, then you're
going to have insular cortex problems.
And that's going to lead to the feeling
that experiences are not yours
in some way.
That could manifest as pain,
a symbolic depersonalization,
or it's also in Alexa thymine,
which we didn't talk about today.
But in any case, that gives rise to this
abnormal sensory state,
or if they call it abnormal perception.
So something has gone
wrong with your ability
to feel that experiences belong to you,
thanks to your
insular cortex dysfunction.
And then if you also have
prefrontal cortical dysfunction,
then you can't explain that.
You have no rational insight into that.
And so you end up with the delusion.
Now, just to recap the
assumption here that's shared by Bill
and by Ramirez Bermudez
and his collaborators
is that the first stage
is essentially the same
or similar between depersonalization
experiences and cotard delusion.
Okay, so the anomalous experience
of depersonalization
with rational insight,
well, that's depersonalization.
But if you have an anomalous experience
of depersonalization
with no rational insight,
then you get the cotard delusion.
But and the result,
and this is because of hypo activity
or lesion, maybe in your insula cortex.
But this is
this is where I want to go today.
This is wrong.
This doesn't fit
with a phenomenology of Cotard syndrome
or the neurosis of Cotard syndrome,
which is typically
a profound and catastrophic
reconfiguration of the bodily
and effective lifeworld of the patient.
It's not a restrict
it course I perceptual deficit,
and it's not just
insular cortical dysfunction
because look look at
the variety of conditions
in which you see Cotard vision
just some affective disorder
schizophrenia, syphilis,
several encephalitis hemorrhage
malformation, brain neoplasm of cancer
migraine Parkinson's disease dementia.
This widespread
catastrophic
conditions of,
you know, neural malfunction.
And then you see
cotard delusion.
It's not just in just the insular cortex
and hypoactive. Okay.
And not only that, it's not just cotard
delusion.
It doesn't look like a just like, oh,
it feels as if I'm not here.
If you go back to the initial
description of the symptom
symptomology, it's not just
I feel like I have intact perception
and cognition,
but just feels like it's not mine
or I feel detached from it.
I mean, typically some of Cotard
delusion undergoes completely profound
and quite catastrophic
reconfiguration of their whole life
experience.
They feel like their body is expanding
or constricting or,
you know, that guy felt
as though his organs had dried up.
They can't sleep.
They state urination and sexual function
and everything goes to crazy.
Their appetite is out of whack.
It's a complete catastrophic breakdown.
Often it's progressive,
but there's no doubt about it.
That's a catastrophic breakdown.
Okay, so there's a first when
we can disagree
with the foundational assumption.
But at the same token
but at the same time, at that same point,
it is true that insula malfunction is
associated with Cotard
with depersonalization.
I beg your pardon.
So let's look at that first.
And it's also true
that insula malfunction,
among other things, is
profoundly involved in cotard delusion.
And I think we can see why.
And this is where active inference
makes its appearance and enter stage,
right?
Active inference theory, active inference
and predictive processing provide
this really nice framework to tie
all these ideas together
to explain depersonalization.
Cotard is symbolic and to fit together
the kind of neural correlates,
the phenomenology
and the symptom analogy symptomology.
Okay,
well, first,
let's let's start with the kind of
the restricted thing.
Let's talk about depersonalization.
Why would insulin
damage lead to depersonalization?
Why would it be the case that if you had
hypo activity in your insular cortex,
you would feel like your experience
wasn't happening to you?
It's pretty interesting.
An amazing sensation.
Well, the reason is that the
insular cortex, it does a lot of things.
You know, as they say, it's an enigmatic
and ubiquitously involved
neural structure.
It's very kind of deep.
It's kind of it receives afferents
from almost everywhere.
It communicates with almost
every every part of the brain.
Okay.
And you'll see
it involved in in so many things.
So it's hard to it's always
been very hard
to work out a particular function
that the insular cortex does.
Right.
It's not like, for example, looking at
part of the visual cortex that, you know,
processes wavelength information
or something like that or is involved in
this.
These neural circuits
are involved in determining movement
or trajectory or something like that.
It's not like that.
The insular cortex somehow
seems to contribute to so many things
as a as an integrative
device of integration,
and I would say as a device
of organization and coordination.
It's like a relay station actually
between all these other different things.
But the posterior
insular cortex is very important
in some out of sensory
vestibular and motor integration.
Okay, so that the posterior
insular cortex is basically involved,
I would say, in integrating
all the information
about what's happening in your body.
Right.
While the anterior insular cortex,
which is our real culprit
here, has present projections,
the limbic regions, which are nervous,
that's one of the substrates
of emotional processes
and is associated with integrating
autonomic and visceral information.
In other words, the basic information
about how your body is functioning.
My my
blood pressure, my blood acidification,
oxygenation, you know, state of my organs
and so forth.
This kind of really basic
keeping you alive, kind of information,
integrating that with emotional,
cognitive and motivational functions,
in other words, and here's the killer.
It brings internal signals
into consciousness and emotion,
interpretations
supporting the neural constructions of
subjective feelings.
So just to go
study for a moment.
So the thought that we get with people
like Budd, Craig and everything like that
is that the anterior insular cortex
basically takes all these signals
about what's happening on the inside,
on the inside of your body.
You know, my blood pressure's up.
My heart is beating, whatever.
My organs are functioning well or not,
and integrates that with all the other
cognitive systems that are telling you
what's going on outside.
You know, what you see,
what you hear, what you smell.
And the higher cognition,
what you remember, what you mentioned,
what thinking about.
Okay.
And it creates it integrates all this, in
other words, to kind of to allow you to
to create if you like, a representation
of how what is happening in the world
is interacting
with what's happening inside my body
to enable me to function
adaptively in context.
And as they say, well, what is that?
Except a sense of self,
the sense of the sense of self
or representation of the self is I'm
the thing that has to manipulate
my body around the world to interact
and engage adaptively with it.
And to do that,
I need to integrate all the information
that's relevant to that task.
That's what we need
a sense of self for,
and that's what the anterior insula does.
Anterior insula
looks down at the bodily processing,
looks out to the world
and integrates them to give you a sense
of, as I say,
subjective feeling in the moment now.
So with that
in place, we can see why when
anterior insula goes wrong
or malfunctions,
you might get a the sense
of not being involved in experience.
Now, the most
persuasive, I think, explanation
of how this might go wrong
is that it's a dissociative response
to trauma.
This comes from Medford Square and David
and the people that work on it,
but they explain it
in kind of emotional terms.
So they call it they call the result
this emotional numbing.
So the thought is you're having
a traumatic experience.
You're being raped or being bashed,
or maybe you're in a destructive,
abusive environment and
as a way of coping, you know, your
your your brain shuts down the anterior
cingulate cortex.
It just turn it it's turns it off.
And what is the result?
You still end up you still end up seeing,
feeling, thinking and so on.
But you don't have the kind of affective,
as I say, effective response or this,
as Sierra puts it, you no longer have
the emotional coloring of experience.
So it leads to a qualitative change
of conscious awareness,
which is reported by the subject
as unreal or detached.
So the basic idea is you shut down
affective processing
so that you can cope with extreme
distress or trauma.
And to shut that down,
you shut off the anterior
insular cortex so you no longer feel
that it's happening to you.
So you can see what you have here
is really an effective
or an emotional theory of
self awareness.
A basic idea is self awareness
is really created by the emotional
coloring of experience,
and when that is gone,
you end up in a emotionally monochrome
world, so to speak.
And there's some evidence
that lack of interior insulate insulates
related to diminished
emotional responsiveness seen in DPD,
and that when the insula
comes back online,
not only they restore
the affective responses, you know,
then they start to feel
that they are this feeling of detachment
and disengagement disappears.
I just made the point that this theory of
this theory, this inhibitory theory of
depersonalization is dissociative,
is actually
it really requires
a predictive processing framework,
because it's not just the fact,
for example, that
the subject doesn't
feel effective responses.
It is the fact that it doesn't
feel effective responses in context.
So conditions where they are predicted,
where they should occur
in a said depersonalization arises
when, you know,
I don't know, take take a mother
who's just given birth and then someone
gives her the child to cuddle or nurse
and she doesn't feel anything right.
Or you come home from a long trip there,
children run up and jump into your arms
and give you a big hug.
You don't feel anything or you know,
you hear bad news.
You do terrible news.
Someone has died or whatever.
Don't feel anything now.
It's not just that
you don't feel anything.
That's the problem.
It's that your mind predicts
that you should
your mind has this kind of ongoing model
of the world and you and you in the world
that your progress through the world
and your interactions with the world
will be, as I say, emotionally colored,
and there's emotional colorings
or affective responses
which get you around the world.
And when that's gone, right, it's
not just that it's gone.
So you you know,
because we have plenty of experiences
that are emotionally
neutral walking down the street,
you know, I don't know,
doing a tax return, reading a book.
You're not especially interested in all
that kind of jazz, listening to a talk,
you know, going
going to the parliament meeting
or that is a slightly distressing
experience.
But, you know you know what I mean?
The mere fact that there's
no effective response
doesn't make you feel depersonalized.
It's the loss of effective response in
a condition where your mind predicts it.
It's that it's the
it's the disjunction between or the
the contradiction
between there should be an effect,
and now there isn't.
And that's reported by and that's
that's always I feel like I'm not here.
Okay.
And so the hypothesized mechanism
is that the you in a traumatic situation
and it's too much for your
brain to deal with
so these inhibitory processes kick in
to shut down the affect your response
in the moment as a dissociative
and it's an inhibition of the anterior
insular cortex
by these inhibitory structures like
and this is exactly what I just said
why that produces
depersonalization is because affective
experience is important in
in getting around life.
And also it's predicted
in your mind's model of
you acting in the world
is that you will have it
have affective responses to the world.
But here's where the affective inference
starts to kick in.
Okay.
So then the question is
how does the mind predict
that your progress through
the world will have
it will give rise
to affective experiences?
And how does it do that?
Well, I think it does
so in a process of what is called
inactive inference framework,
predictive processing
framework, hierarchical self modeling.
Okay.
And basically hierarchical self modeling
is, as I said before briefly, that
just as the mind
makes models
or representations of the external world,
the world out there
in terms of its causal structure
in the mind has to make a model of what's
going on inside the body
in terms of its causal structure.
And the way the mind does this is
by integrating all the properties
and features of the world
and attributing them to unified,
persisting causes.
Well, that's objects.
In the case of the external world, that
unified assisting causes are objects.
You know, you don't see smears of colors
and movements and changes.
You see cars driving down the railway.
You don't see these kind of weird
interacting shapes and properties.
You see people's faces smiling and so on.
So it's kind of obligatory strategy
for the mind to integrate
properties and features
by attributing them to underlying
objects or in the case of substances,
if you want to call it
that unified, persisting things.
Right.
And that's what
that's what we do in outward.
And the idea of the idea of the self
modeling framework is that's what we do
inward as well.
The mind's obligatory strategy
is to unify
and integrate
when there are regular, coherent,
predictable
flows and sequences
of experiences or sensory information.
The mind explains that,
if you like, interprets it predicted
by attributing it to the same object.
This happens at multiple levels, right?
At the most basic level,
you know, you have to integrate
all these different, different
I mean, esthetic functioning,
you know, blood pressure,
visceral dilation,
you know, vascular dilation,
all this kind of stuff
that keeps you going.
Well, actually, you don't
that is actually integrated
into by attributing all of those things
as occurring in the same entity.
And we feel the result in what
in an introspective state
introspection
being the internal analog of perception.
So example
which makes this point well I think is
fatigue, right?
Well, when you are fatigued.
Right. What do you feel?
You feel like I'm fatigued.
The thing, you know,
the embodied thing feels depleted.
But you don't feel
all these individual streams of,
you know, glycogen
depletion, adenosine
depletion, slow metabolism and all that,
you just get the kind of overall vibe of,
I'm tired
and that's good
because then you can go to sleep.
You don't have to fine tune anyway.
You can't you can't get in there
and change your glycogen levels
or anything like that.
You can just eat.
So hunger is another example of the kind
of introspective sensation that is,
you know, this does this kind of
aggregate of an integrative thing and
this kind of type of self modeling.
This is very familiar
from the predictive process
from from
that takes place at multiple levels
given the kind of imperatives
that we have to survive.
So let
me just spend a little bit it's okay
at the most within the act of inference
framework.
Okay.
The most basic task of any organism
self-organizing system is to
is to survive.
It has to maintain its
source, maintain its physical integrity,
you know, its boundary with the world.
It has to take in energy from the world.
It has to and so on has to engage with
the world, taking energy from the world.
And then it has to do something
with that energy to maintain itself
to keep all its components interacting.
So that's at the most basic
physical level.
Organisms avoid this inevitable tendency
to thermodynamic decay
that we all face, and the probabilistic
and analog of that is they avoid entropy.
They have to keep themselves
in a state far, far
from entropy
by taking in energy and using it.
And of course, at the biological level,
what does that actually mean?
That means staying alive, surviving,
prospering in the world.
And the most
when we look at the physiology
and then
obviously we're talking
about homeostatic mechanisms,
we're talking about mechanisms of self
maintenance
for a
for a discrete, unique individual,
so to speak.
Now, they can be able to see cases where
borderline case
of promise homeostasis, where, you know,
where organisms are dependent
on other organisms.
For example, there are lots of cases
where there's a kind of, you know,
crisscrossing of boundaries.
But let's keep it simple for the moment.
Think of a cell or think of an organism.
Got to maintain their
their basic functioning.
And that's what we refer
to as homeostasis, or at least this
slightly larger,
more sophisticated concept.
So these are the kind of basic
physical imperatives.
But of course, to do that,
there has to be a lot of signaling
within the system.
You know, the levels of levels
of endocrine function, levels of blood
pressure, levels of blood oxygenation,
they are signaled
to a brain or proto brain or mind,
if you want to call it that.
And that signaling, okay, that signaling
requires that the organism
in some sense implement or maintain the
model which predicts what is
what is
optimal for
it, how far it's departing from optimal,
and whether the actions
that it's taking to get back into
optimal range are successful.
And when it can do that,
when it can successfully model itself,
then it's minimizing
what they call variational free energy.
And the surprise here
just refers to the departure from
the predicted optimal state,
given the organisms action.
Now, if that sounds too abstract,
just think, you know, here's your brain
and you're writing up your saying to ride
your bike up a hill or walk up stairs,
and you have a kind of good optimal
range of heartbeat function and blood
oxygenation.
Okay, but that needs to change now
because you're walking upstairs, right?
You need to
you need more oxygen in your blood.
You need to work harder
and raise your heartbeat.
So your mind sense, if you like.
Brain sends instructions, right? Happy.
This is all at the kind of signaling
level that's quite dynamic.
If your heartbeat goes up, that's good.
It should be up
when you're going upstairs
and it should be up
if you're riding a bike up a hill.
So you've minimized know free energy.
You've stayed within your optimal bound.
Okay, in not getting in the information
that's out of
out of the kind of predicted
and that violates a prediction model
for that situation.
But let's say that
you come back downstairs and you sit down
and you're resting and having a drink
and your heartbeat is still rising.
Well, that's outside optimal range.
That's not what your
body and mind,
you know, predict for that situation.
Your brain
thinking your brain doesn't do well.
Your brain doesn't think that.
And now are signals saying
this is out of kilter.
I'm sitting on my couch and I have
it is 200 or under.
I'm sweating, sweating furiously,
but I'm not riding my bike.
Okay. And it's not 40 degrees outside.
What's going on?
I've got a lot of signaling
going on all the time
about whether and how you are optimizing
your bodily function.
And so that just at the level
of signaling and some
that's very, very dynamic and leads
these kind of automatic adjustments.
But of course at a higher
level when you talk about
cognition, well, what
they can think of the mind
or as what we call cognition
as a construction of sort
of representational computation systems
that exploit
these informational properties
or that organized states, intimate,
emotional and signaling properties
so that we end up
with a representational architecture.
That's how we get perception, memory,
sensory, motor control and so on.
And what
that's what the theory of computation
gives us for understanding the mind.
It gives us what
the theory of computation basically is
and its most abstract is turning
information information and signaling
into representation
representations that can be manipulated.
Okay, translate these abstract ideas
into the idea of self modeling.
And we get something like this,
we get at the very basic level
of organismic function.
Then you have
an esthetic or a homeostatic
integration.
Your mind is kind of,
you know, your brain is looking around,
am I in or out of
am I in or out of optimal functioning?
All this signaling is going on
and what we call into reception
is the integration of those processes,
okay, which attributes them to the thing
which is being regulated
the same, which is being managed.
Okay. The thing in which all of these
processes have to cohere
to enable adaptive functioning.
And then we get a readout of that.
And the readout is your intercept.
You feel fatigue,
you know, if you feel tired,
that's because, you know, glycogen
depletion, adenosine levels
have changed, your metabolism is slow,
blah, blah, blah.
Muscles are weaker
and not contracting as fast.
And you feel that as fatigue,
as it's integration of all of those
allosteric variables.
And that happens
basically the job of the posterior
insular cortex written
there API is to do that.
That's all that stuff coheres, right?
That's where all of that stuff coheres.
Then of course
there's not just the issue of
how is my body functioning?
That's one thing.
It's my body just, well, yeah,
that's important to note.
But then there's a separate
kind of what we might call
high level
issue of the meaning and signifier sense
of those bodily processes
for you in context, right?
So if your heart is racing
and you are riding a bike up a hill
or going forward in the gym,
that's a good thing.
But that shouldn't cause you
any particular distress
you'll feel that is exhaustion.
But if your heartbeat is racing
because you're waiting for your cancer
test, you know,
and the doctor has just come back,
just come out of his office
and he's looking at the
he's looking at your chart
and he's looking at your
is looking at your
ultrasound
with a look of concern and worry.
Now your heart is racing, right?
Why is it racing?
Because you're worried that you've got
worried that you might have cancer.
That's a different thing.
But the point is
that the feeling is different.
The feeling of worry, distress,
anticipatory anxiety.
Well,
that is characterized by racing heartbeat
and and feelings of tension and so on.
But that's the same bodily signature
that you can get
when you're powering uphill on your bike
or, you know, or something like that.
So the level of copy in itself
is, as it were, you know, effectively
or emotionally neutral,
what that level of heartbeat depends on
and how it
and how you should react to it.
Well, that's a product of that kind
of emotional context.
And to understand the emotional context,
that's when you need to bring in
the rest of your perceptual memory
and so on, faculties
and indeed your self representation,
how I am functioning in the world.
And so to do that you need to interpret
or I put it here, transcribe
those bodily feelings
into emotional feelings of sadness
or anxiety or whatever they are.
I've given the example here of fatigue
because it comes up later,
but it's also a good one, right?
If you're fatigued, you know,
if you're just tired
or that is a certain bodily feeling,
no doubt about it.
But If you're depressed, you know
someone who's got persistent depression.
They also feel fatigued.
They feel tired, lethargic, apathetic,
unmotivated, energetic,
but fatigue in an episode or sorry,
the energy bodily.
Deanna Judge the bodily energy ization
in an episode of
sadness is experienced differently
to just fatigue.
That's the point. Right. And why is that?
Because in an episode of Sadness
The World and your prospects
in it have been appraised or evaluated
or colonized.
Choose your term.
That is because your
your mind has basically determined
that the world for you is a sort of
irretrievable dis consolation.
You know, there's losses in there
that you can't recover or recapture.
And of course, so
that produces the feelings of sadness.
Okay. So
why does this so
when we translate it into self modeling,
you've got the kind of physical level
of bodily functioning and that kind of
homeostatic and signaling stuff.
But then in order to interpret
the significance of all of those changes,
you need a model.
The mind needs a model of your organism
and how it's functioning in the world
and what it should expect from the world
and the kind of affective consequences
that it should get from the world.
And so it makes
multilevel
self model at the most basic level,
at the most basic level
that the mind models itself
as an as a unified entity
in which
all of these bodily signals cohere.
And then it can use that model
to regulate the body.
You can go to sleep if you're tired
at a higher level, slightly.
The mind models itself as the entity
that has these feelings, these feelings
of these affective feelings,
these feelings of sadness, anxiety,
or these feelings of happiness,
pleasure, resentment,
you know, all these subtle feelings
that are modulated by your actions
as you go through the world.
So just as you need a model of the
the bodily functioning
to model the body at a basic level,
to control once, to cut,
to get through the world
while we get through the world
by acting to manipulate our feelings. So
we need a higher level model of our self
as the subject of affective states.
And here's
to at the higher that's still higher
level still,
we report those feelings
in a kind of verbal narrative way.
You know, I'm late for work.
I'm studying,
I'm studying, I'm practicing gymnastics.
You know, I'm married, etc.,
all these things.
Well, this is just the kind
of the high level narrative self model
that we use to report our feeling.
We used to report our states
and communicate them
and engage with other people.
And so we engage at this narrative level.
There's a narrative level, self model
that's kind of linguistic,
but the narrative level self model
is supported by a affective
or emotional level because as we engage
with other people and report our states,
what we're doing
is doing that to change how it changes
the way we feel, feel better
and at a still lower level,
those affective feelings, what are they?
They are transcribed bodily feelings.
That is to say, I emotionally interpreted
bodily feelings.
So the the self model is a hierarchies
hierarchical basic level.
It's it's understood at a higher level
it's bodily as interpreted
for its emotional significance
and at the highest level, it's narrative.
Now here's your here's the hypothesis
about all these disorders
in a cotard delusion, the self model
just disintegrates from the bottom up.
It just falls to bits,
it falls to bits at the
physical level right.
And in other words, this
the system becomes
unregulated and unpredictable,
but the mind is sending
is mind is sending signals control, sleep
control, appetite control, metabolism
control movement in a get up to. But
they're not getting any traction.
They're not getting any feedback.
They the whole kind of modeling
structure is disintegrated
so that what the mind learns
so that the mind actually
can't make and model, which predicts
the functioning of the organism.
It still has this kind of sensations
of organism function, but they're not
integrated, unified and model
as belonging to a continuum thing
because and that's precisely
because that model is made
for the purposes of regulation, right?
And when the mind
and when the body becomes
whole, the mind learns that there is no
there is no model that's going to predict
and regulate its behavior.
And so, in other words, if you think of
the self as a model that the
the mind makes at the most basic level
for regulatory purposes,
then when it's,
when it's completely unregulated,
the mind learns that there is
no model that can do the job.
Okay.
We won't say, oh, it's yep.
So that's the
that's my explanation of Cotard.
Okay.
Well, but in depersonalization, it's
not quite like that
because in depersonalization, basically
the model is intact.
Okay, the model is intact.
You've got kind of
control over bodily functioning,
you've got cognition, perception
and so on or working.
But the only thing is that the affective
processes have been inhibited.
So this kind of you're seeing the world
failing the world
touching and engaging with the world.
But there's no
effective responses to the world
because they've been shut down
for as a dissociative response.
So now you've got an intact self model,
but you can't annex
or incorporate affective states into it.
So that's why independent physician
people feel as though they feel as though
their bodies the same, their perceptual
and sensory motor states are the same,
and their narrative ability
to report that think about that.
You know, the high level of cognitive
states and narrative reportage,
they are intact, but effect is missing.
Effect has been, if you like,
detached or taken out of this model
that's otherwise intact.
And that feels as if they don't they feel
detached on the outside of experience.
That's why they they say they report
they feel as if they don't exist,
but they don't say they don't exist
because the models, still
the model is basically intact
just with this subtraction
of its affective component ability
now pain.
And that is as a result of unpredicted
deactivation of the anterior insula
because anterior insulates precisely
the structure that it integrates,
all the processing that does
the evaluative emotional processes
and produces affective responses
in pain symbolic,
which is reported
as a kind of restricted depersonalization
that is actually a problem
at the lower level
because pain symbolic is a problem at the
the lower level of the posterior
insular cortex,
which is more at the level of the sensory
integration,
not the emotional interpretation.
So in pain I symbolic nociceptive signals
are not incorporated in the bodily self,
incorporated in the bodily self model.
So that's a kind of early process.
So once again, in pain symbolically
you've got an intact self model,
bodily
self model, affective and narrative,
but somehow nociceptive signals aren't
being incorporated into that model.
So and since they're not incorporated
into the model at all,
then they won't be transcribed.
Effective levels of self
modeling and then and then
the mind is left with, well,
I'm experiencing nice deceptive signals,
but I'm not.
They're not incorporated in the kind
of bodily self model at the basic level.
So they're not mine, so to speak.
I'm anthropomorphizing
on behalf of the brain here
and then, since they're not incorporated
in the bodily self model,
they're not going to be effectively
interpreted,
interpreted at higher levels
of emotional self modeling.
And once again, the subject is left
at this kind of narrative level,
just reporting
on the subsequent experience.
It feels like the pain is not happening.
To me. Okay.
And so is this self modeling theory.
Well, this self
modeling theory comes from, of course,
effective, sorry, active inference
and predictive processing theories.
Right.
And this is from Seth and Friston.
You know, they say that on
this theory of introspective
slide here, we're going to really
this theory of
things are generated at the bottom level
by this kind of successive interpretation
in terms of models
which are ultimately top down
and within this framework.
And so, as I said, the anterior
insular cortex is specialized to allow us
to integrate information about body
state, to feel its significance.
And the point about the self modeling
theory is those feelings of significance
or fictive feelings are attributed
to a unified, persisting entity.
The self just the self model.
I'm just rehearsing, repeating here
what I've said.
Okay.
And as I say,
this is another way to put it.
What I've just said, emotion
and embodied selfhood are grounded
in active inference of those signals.
Most likely to be made.
In other
words, as you go through the world,
your mind needs to model
the consequences of your actions
and the consequences of those actions
are going to be, you know, introspective,
internal, bodily, and also
they're going to be emotional and affect.
And so at any given time,
we have a self model
which is predicting how our actions
with the world will make us feel
and what the kind of sensory
consequences of those actions will be
at all levels from homeostasis, body
integrity, body integrity and so forth.
And as they say, the metacognitive
cognitive and narrative.
Right, or as I've put it, to simplify,
you've got kind of basic bodily self
you've got and that gets transcribed,
interpreted as a
fictive or emotional self.
And then at the top level, we report
and communicate that with the narrative.
So basically the self
is there to serve as to
to represent the source of endogenous
signals arising from inside
and to be the target
of internal regulation.
And this, this goes back into
Craig's papers in the early
2000.
That put it this way, that, you know,
within the posterior insula that does
the basic bodily stuff, you know,
heartbeat, oxygenation, energy depletion,
and then those representations of basic
body state
get progressively and progressively
remapped at higher levels
exploding more, more, higher
and a modal cognitive processes.
Until we get to the anterior insula,
the anterior insula has to communicate
with these other systems of perception,
memory, inference, imagination
to tell you the experience,
to tell you what to tell you sorry.
What the the meaning, the significance
of all these bodily changes is
and should these bodily changes,
are they adaptive in this situation?
I'm riding my bike uphill.
I had been on my heart's racing when I'm
when I'm having a conversation
with my wife, this is bad.
This is kind of anxiety and so forth.
Okay, I can skip that.
This is just, you know, to say
that the anterior and posterior insula,
you know, they are hubs,
they are not a place where
they are not the kind of
there's not like a self module,
a bodily self module in a affective self
module.
It's more
that they are kind of integrative hubs
that basically direct
traffic is a good way to put on it.
Or another way to think of it
is they like the read write head on a
on a cheering machine. Right.
They're coordinating and doing stuff.
They're integrating stuff across them,
across the brain to this particular task.
All right.
And and they communicate with other hubs,
the prefrontal and amygdala,
which are very important
for collecting for the evaluation,
you know, the prefrontal cortex,
more about collecting information
for at the kind of conceptual level,
you know, thinking about, you know, is
my have I have
I offended someone is that why they said
why the angry or ignoring with me?
Is that because of that kind of thing?
Whereas the amygdala
is more like coordinating information
about basic perceptually driven stuff,
you know, someone raises their voice or
puts on an angry expression, and
within a couple of hundred milliseconds,
I feel a response to that.
So all right.
So so we're going to summarize, right?
These are just a couple of quotations
about the insula from various things
can. Let's just read one.
Right,
the convergence of multimodal sensory
information and ability
to read out subjective states explains
the insula is intimately involved
in affective processing.
Correct.
Okay.
It's functionally important
for further treatment.
Certainly an information
and interfacing between physiology
and higher order cognitive systems.
And that's
why it's so functionally ubiquitous
and connected with so many things.
To form a silence detection network.
It allows us to feel how things matter,
like they're done within the predictive
processing and active inference.
It's not just you feel salience.
Salience means salient to me,
relevant to the organism
and its prospects.
But it's something can be salient
unless it's relevant to a goal, relevant,
relevant to a goal of survival
or of salient to a goal of, you know,
maintaining social relationships
or achieving some ambition.
So salience is not something in itself.
Salience is relative to particular goals
of organismic survival
or organism clustering at various levels.
And in order to do that, my needs,
the model itself
as the bearer of the goals
as the thing is, is prospering or not.
Is it affected by its actions?
Now he's the thought that is ethic.
If you have just like
you have bodily states like interception,
you have affected
states like anxiety or depression.
And what they what those states do
is they tell you
how your prospering, they tell you
how you're prospering bodily
and they tell you how you prospering
emotionally, which is great.
And the good thing about that is
then you can act like you can perform
your active inference
of arguing the world
for solutions, of moving around
and sampling sensations
and trying out activities and so forth.
All this kind of ways of engaging
with the world that is going to optimize
your ability to build a model of yourself
as a functioning system,
but you don't actually have to fine tune
all that kind of the mechanisms
and low level systems.
And that's good because we count, right?
So if you think about fatigue,
I cannot go in and change the metabolism
of all my cells.
I can't go in and change adenosine levels
and I can't change the balance
of serotonin and acetylcholine
across my brain.
But I can go to sleep.
So I manage the feeling of exhaustion
and then I wake up feeling better,
having optimized my optimize
my organism, optimize
my organism by manage my feelings.
And similarly, at a sort of higher level
of the emotional functioning,
I optimize my organism by managing
affective or emotional feelings.
So, you know,
if I actually said I was full of life
and I need to avoid the context
that makes me sad.
If I feel happy,
then I'll keep doing what I'm doing,
you know,
if I feel amused or interested
or engaged,
then that'll lead me to kind of pursue
and keep performing the actions
that are rewarding and so on and so on.
And so life then becomes
a matter of acting to regulate effect
by active inference as a proxy
for minimizing predictive error or in
other words, optimizing organism function
across the
functioning of the organism.
So in other words and the self here is
the thing is
the self is modeled as the thing
which sustains these feelings.
And the thing is feelings can be changed
by active inference or action.
Then that's the role of the self.
The role of the self is to be the entity
that we can manipulate.
Okay, so in this sense, active inference
is like a proxy
for overall organismic regulation.
Okay.
So the self, the feeling of being the
feeling of being a unified, persisting
self allows us to get through the world
by manipulating our feelings.
So the self model, it's like the airplane
icon on a control panel on a plane
or a pilot flight, a Boeing 737
or four seven or whatever.
But manipulating the controls
and I can see on his panel
now the little model of the plane
banking or going up and down.
Well, that's great,
because the pilot has no access
to the electronics, the software,
the hydraulics,
you know, all the mechanisms. Right.
Pilot and pilots are going to go back
down to the tail
and try and change the ailerons
or anything like that.
And the pilot's
not going to go in there and,
you know, mess around with the software
of the computer that controls the system.
That's all delegated, right?
That's the way them all the pilot has
to do is manipulate the icon.
And that's what we have to do.
We have to just act to make ourself
feel better.
And the self is just the target
that regulatory actions.
Let's get
this now because I think I'm actually
finished. I'm really running out of time.
So to sum up for our case of the art of
the Cotard Delusion,
and these are the things
well, in the Cotard delusion,
what happens is you have a version
of what these theorists step
on an alcohol catastrophic dysregulation.
So in the case of MDMA, encephalitis,
right,
cellular metabolic function,
the whole thing is kind of
out of whack because of this pervasive
inflammation across the brain.
And so there can't be any kind of low
level signaling that's working.
And at the time
a representation of levels.
You won't getting any kind of consistent,
accurate representations
when it's kind of converted
into computational language.
So the brain is distributable,
the body is distributable.
So the system learns the system learns
that as a regulatory system,
as a target of regulation,
it doesn't exist.
Of course it's that
is that just to say this
model disappears,
but you can still feel your body.
It's just that those feelings
want integrated into or model
of something that you can change
and regulate and predict and anticipate.
Okay, so let's call it dysregulation.
So I thought about that, my final slide,
and it's got a typo on it.
So I'll change that after this. But
just to remind you and I'll close up now
because we need to talk about Descartes
famously said
that it's like hunger and thirst.
They teach us that we're not present
in our bodies as a sailor, his ship,
but we are closely
joined and intermingled with it.
So I compose a single thing with my body.
In my body, I feel like I in my body,
we might say within predictive
processing, that the experience
of being the subject of introspective
and effective experiences
produces the feeling of the inference
that those experiences
belong to a simple, unified thing.
And the more that I succeed
in controlling myself
by regulating my experiences,
introspective and effective experiences,
the more I learn that I am that thing.
You know, when I eat, I'm satiated.
When I achieve a goal, I'm happy
and I'm worried and I result my worries.
But states of intractable
dis homeostasis teach us the reverse.
In severe
cases like in the case of lettuce,
the mind has to end up learns
that there's no viable regulatory target
because experience is chaotic
and unpredictable.
So you can't keep entropy at bay
right now
and keep entropy at bay
at the most basic level.
By having a kind of model that works,
then your biological functioning
messed up
and you've got no physiological control.
All the signaling goes to pieces.
You can't
minimize variational free energy, and
that is at the representational level.
The self model disintegrates.
There's no kind of self model
that predictably enables you
to regulate yourself, and you're
just with this kind of chaotic experience
and the cotard delusion which you report
with the kind of the shadow
that's all you've got
left, is a linguistic functioning
you've just got linguistic functioning.
Looks like
you just got the reporting talking.
So that one Cotard patient famously said,
I'm just a voice,
and if that goes, I won't be anything.
If my voice goes, I'll be lost
and I won't know where I've gone.
So the patients,
this is the patient's only response
to this intractable sense
of bodily affective entropy.
The center, the narrative.
I completely disconnected
from the structure of bodily ineffective
experiences that normally anchor it
because this model has fallen to pieces.
And I should stop there because
I've been going for a long time.
Thank you.
I did read and we can talk a little bit.
It's just as long as you'd like.
Yeah, sure.
Same buttons to share
and then you a cool.
I wrote down a ton of stuff.
There were some questions in the chat,
so thanks for the awesome talk.
I'll start with one of Dave's.
So Dave had written
does your evolutionary and neurological
exploration of delusion especially of the
pathologies of the prefrontal cortex,
functional connectivity
preclude the validity
of psychological approaches.
Or how do psychological
and psychosocial approaches
benefit from a corporate incorporating
these kinds of methods and findings?
Okay. Well, that's a very good question.
I don't think they preclude at all right.
I think the I think they're vital
to psychological approach.
I mean, I did write a chapter in a book
I wrote a while about this, but
I don't there's a bad tendency
in psychiatry in the world
to think, okay,
you've got psychological approaches,
you've got people's thoughts, experiences
and feelings, and then you have
the kind of things
that biological psychiatry does,
you know, molecular level interventions
with receptors and serotonin,
and that they never
they never talk to each other.
Right.
And so you have a disease
model of mental illness
and you have a psychosocial model
of mental illness in all this.
But clearly, that's wrong. Right.
And it's got to be wrong
because if you think of think of a
just an example like astigmatism or,
you know, macular degeneration,
that's something that you experience
at a personal
and experiential level as, you know,
loss of part of your visual field.
If you've got a black spot in your visual
field, that affects how you experience
the world, how you get around it,
how you interact with other people.
And there's a mechanical explanation
there, which is in terms of,
you know, the visual visual cortex
or the retina or
and the capillaries and all that in that.
Okay.
Well, why why would it be the case?
And if someone said to you, oh, well,
look, you know, we could only have
like a personal level and
experiential, phenomenological account of
of visual experience.
You'd say that was mad.
So I want to go to the eye specialist
and he knows all about, you know,
how diabetes produces.
It's because we have a mechanical thing,
but not only that
the mechanical explanation
depends on a computational explanation
of how a vision works.
These cells in the retina
get bombarded by photons.
They forget in the mind,
progressively reconstructs
an image of the image
of the causes of that bombardment.
And that's how visual experience.
So I can tell you why
macular degeneration at any level, at the
level of the retina or why visual cortex
is going to affect your experience.
And we think that's all in order.
And we think that's
exactly the way to do it.
Why wouldn't we think
of that for the Cotard delusion or for
or for,
you know, any psychiatric disorder,
anxiety or whatever?
It's not that you've got
this kind of autonomous level of
autonomous level of, you know, molecular
level interventions, and then you've got
some phenomenological level of experience
and thinking.
I mean, one depends on one,
it depends on the other.
I just think that's like that. Yes.
So in my view,
the right what we're trying to do is
is try and understand what's happening
in the intervening level.
And that's what
areas of visual processing do you know
are you got artificial theories
and you've got neurological theories
and they come together
and that's what the active inference
self modeling theory is supposed to do.
In these cases
of pathologies, of self-awareness,
you have a kind of experience
of your self has changed,
and we know that that's because something
is happening in your body and brain.
How are we supposed to explain that?
We're not just correlate the change
in experience with the low level cold?
We want to say that's
because these changes in your body
and brain are organized
to do this information processing.
The computational
representational functions.
And when you get these low level changes,
they compromise this functioning,
this computational level,
working with the result
that you have these experiences.
And it goes the other way.
You know, when someone
you get information from the world,
it has to filter all the way down
by being represented process somehow.
You know, we have to take a
stand on the nature of the the nature
of the computation, whether it's wide,
narrow, symbolic neural network,
whatever that's ongoing project.
So that's my it's
my thoughts on that topic.
Thank you
so the next question is from Dean,
who wrote,
does this
does the disassociation of feelings
leave the person not able to make plan
because in some way their predictive
model has been compromised?
So how do these people, you know,
do they grasp objects appropriately?
Could they get across town on the bus?
What level or in what ways
is their action prediction changed?
Yeah, well, I think you know,
I think people
who are very effectively
flattened and depersonalized,
I think planning is an issue.
Planning is an issue for them
precisely because, you know,
of the of the idea that, you know,
if you're trying to decide
where to go for holidays
or whether to get married
or whether to quit your job, it's
not just to sort
of called cognitive process
of weighing the costs and benefits.
Those things have to be felt right.
Know, you decide
who am I going to go to Hawaii where it's
warm and pleasant,
or am I going to go to Alaskan Rescue?
Well, how does you mentally rehearse
those options
and how that makes you feel determines
the decision, you know?
And if you decide to get divorced
or get married, it's not just all, yeah,
you know, if I get married, this
and this and this will happen.
And if I get divorced,
the likelihood of this,
it's more like
that makes you feel a certain way.
So your life becomes
effectively flattened.
So that perception and cognition
of all the various
options for action
are now effectively neutral.
It does make it very hard to
to plan and engage.
And in the end, I think what you find in
depersonalization is
people just kind of go through
the motions with their habitual actions,
you know?
So if you're a bus driver
or a university lecturer
or a husband and parents,
then then you feel depersonalized.
Then you just
you keep doing what you're doing,
but you feel like just an empty shell
going through the motions.
But those people have a lot of difficulty
coming up with a coherent
alternative plan.
It's like,
why don't you do something else?
Why don't you you know?
But but we see this actually,
you know, even in
an everyday case of life, you know,
you might know that it would be good
if you took up exercise, but would be
as a objective piece of knowledge.
It would be great if I took up, you know,
bike riding or if I went on a diet
or if, you know,
whatever, if I moved cities. But
but you just
know that as a kind of, you know,
piece of information, it won't make
you do it unless that somehow can click
in to your affective self model.
It's like, Yeah, it's me.
Oh, I can kind of imagine myself
as, you know, whatever
it is riding up the hill, walking up,
you know, having some future
that I can actually inhabit,
not just intellectually,
but also emotionally and personally.
Well, just one on that
and then I'll read a question from Dave.
It's like in a way,
society is a big top down.
Like in active inference.
We talk a lot about nested systems
and you focused on sort of the level
of bodily integrity and the brain body.
But in a sense
the social structure are niche scaffolds.
Our behavior, whether it's
hey, it doesn't matter if you don't like
broccoli, you're going to put
that fork in your mouth or whether it's
some other type of decision there,
top down priors that actually structure
our decision making and planning
in the absence of precision or of
a good way to plan.
So just really interesting there.
I think that's exactly right.
And, you know,
I think this is really your point.
Exactly.
Applies really, really well to addiction.
There's a woman called Hanna Pickard
who writes extensively on addiction.
And what she points out is that an addict
can know that if they stop taking drugs,
it would be better for them.
But so what they need to be able to do
is project themself
into the non addicted future where
they're living, engaging in the world
and they're getting positive feedback
from the world.
But she says to her, to pick up
your point,
that's very hard
to have a model of yourself like that
without social scaffolding without social
structure, without a kind of positive
or without a kind of positive feedback
and structure from a world around you.
So the thought is
that the self that you are, is,
is, as you say, your priors,
your predictions.
They're not just about internal modeling.
They're also about the priors
expected nations and plans and plans
and reinforcement that you get from being
immersed in a sort of social milieu.
And for addicts, that's not there.
They can't imagine that they have
no model of themself as functioning
in an alternative social media.
So when they get out
of jail or get out of rehab,
unfortunately,
they get back in their old social milieu,
the familiar triggering situations
in the familiar social environment,
and that kind of activates
their self model.
As someone who who does
does that and they're
and she says
when you ask them to reflect on
what it's like as a non addict,
imagine they can't.
There's a kind, she said it induces
in them a kind of existential terror
because they really can't
imagine themself as a non
non addicted life.
It's kind of it's an empty future
for them, partly because she says there's
no viable social scaffolding to support
their they're like in that world.
So your point is, I think plays really
well into that, that literature, that.
And what you said there.
What is it like to be,
you know, in that case, not addicted to
a substance or a behavior?
It's kind of a subtle allusion
to the famous
philosophical tradition of what is it
like to be a bat to be an ant colony.
Right.
And when you brought up,
I think even at the beginning,
you said,
what is it like to feel you don't exist?
That this idea of negative space
and of negation came up in such
interesting ways in the talk?
Like if you ask somebody,
what does it feel like to exist?
It's like, that's 99% of the discourse
or, you know, that's the mystery.
But then by drawing our attention,
what would it feel like?
Counterfactual import for argument?
What would it feel like to not exist
as I know, I'm not feeling that.
So what is that one?
And then what's the other side of the
coin of feeling like I don't exist?
It's like.
It's like feeling like I am in control,
like I am steering.
Exactly.
So that was so such a cool connection.
That's that. Yeah,
I think that's the point.
I want to, I wanted to get at the what
why I like the active inference framework
for this is because
the feeling
of being me, you know, a lot of people
tell you,
oh, well, if you have a perceptual,
then someone's having it.
You know,
an experience has to have an experience
or something like that
or how can you not feel like you're me?
If you have a body, you can
your body touch your body and feel it.
But that's not what we're talking about.
The feeling of being me
is the feeling of being in charge.
The feeling of being the thing
that I can manipulate
in order
to bring about all these experiences.
And you can still have experiences.
You can see plenty of experiences,
but if you lose the feeling
that those experiences
are things that you can change
and manipulate dependent on your,
then you lose
the experience of being you.
And that's at a high level,
but the same thing.
Imagine the thing going right down
really low.
Your hypothalamus is sending
to raise your heartbeat and
not getting any feedback.
Your heartbeat stays
low, stays obstinately low
or obstinately high.
It's the same thing.
I'm not I'm not getting any traction
here.
Obviously,
a hypothalamus doesn't think that.
But, you know, or,
you know, imagine a bacterium
that's trying to contract membranes
to turn left to pursue a sugar gradient.
And nothing's happening.
It's getting, keeping,
getting this kind of obstinate feeling
that I'm not in charge anymore
and I've got no moral
I've got no model on myself
that's working to
the to give me the feeling of being me.
And that's in such a case,
the system still has sensory experience,
so an activity at its receptors
and stuff is happening, but it's just not
a regulatory target anymore.
And that makes me think about
when you talked about
the people who are suffering from pain,
but they're disassociated from it.
It feels like it's not their pain.
It's little wordplay.
So it's not a philosophical argument,
but gnosis and no deception.
It's like, yep,
there's the knowledge of pain,
but actually it's almost inseparable
from the suffering.
Right?
And so this is an extreme case
where the gnosis of no deception
has been entirely separated
from the narrative of the self.
It's like,
yeah, there is pain in the arm.
But exactly. It's
not part of my narrative.
And so there's
the person psychologically.
That's exactly right.
There's damage.
There's damage to the body
that I inhabit,
especially what the brain is saying.
The body,
this body that I live in is damaged,
but it's not my damage. No.
Do they ever ask whose is it
or does it just not seem to be like, oh,
just like know someone's car,
someone's parked outside?
Or is it like I'm it's like.
No, no.
The really interesting thing,
I mean, the early cases,
the really interesting thing
about pain symbolic is that
they don't take any action to avoid pain.
So that in that sense,
you know, that's really bad.
And so but it's not quite
the same as congenital
insensitivity to pain, which is a problem
with the receptor level right?
Those people don't detect pain.
And so, you know, they're in a bad way.
They put their hand on a burning stove,
they break their legs and they don't
they just don't feel don't
even have the bodily sensation.
But pain is symbolic.
They have the bodily sensation,
but they don't annex it to themself.
Or it points to different roles
for different receptors.
So I wanted to ask about
the NMDA receptor, which you kind of
brought up in the beginning.
What does the NMDA receptor do
neurologically or
why is it associated with that phenotype?
Right.
Well, now you're now you're now, now,
now about a month
now I'm out of my league.
But it I think that
that kind of encephalitis
is a inflammatory thing.
Right. It's an inflammatory response.
And so when it hits those receptors,
I think it's just because
MDMA is like it's
so widespread throughout the brain.
I think it's like a
I'm talking out of turn here.
Right.
So it's it's not my
my field so canceled this but
I think it's like like a like a catalyst
or modulator
for so many metabolic functions.
Right.
It's involved in everything
as a kind of very fundamental thing.
So when you mess with it,
you pretty much you.
That's why you get this kind
of catastrophic dysregulation
across the brain.
Yeah, that's that's the thought.
It's one of these. It's like
adenosine or something like
that, you know,
that these metabolism depends on that.
And if you mess that up
or what's another one, the ketones,
you know, if you if you get a buildup
of ketone in the brain,
you know, it's it's tiny chemical.
But if tiny levels of this chemical
can just destroy everything, produce
mental retardation, mutism, motor
disorders, it's a catastrophe,
an absolute catastrophe,
because, you know,
the cellular level of functioning
is so dependent on these nano nano level
adjustments of these basic things.
That speaks
to two dimensions of the challenge,
which is the multi scale systems.
There's little things like molecules
and big things like people,
and then also the trans disciplinary
and it's like we should have one story
for one level from one discipline
and then a separate discipline.
In a separate story, we need something
like an integrated approach.
What's that going to be?
That's exactly right.
And so where I suppose,
where I came into this when I was
when I got into philosophy,
most people thought, well,
what's the integrative story going to be?
Well, you know, it's some kind of
computational story, you know, top down
classical computational modeling, CPU,
modular inputs, modular outputs.
That's one way.
It's a kind of broad brush approach.
Then you have neural network stories
and then you have,
you know, deep learning stories
and all these different architectures.
And now you have it
and I have active inference and depends
what you think active inference
is going to how it's going to play out.
I mean,
if you think of active inference as
you know at the biophysical level,
it sounds right, but it's very abstract,
right?
It treats like a human organism
as like a physical system in space.
It's like a self-organizing asteroid
or something like that.
It's really the same.
The same laws of physics apply,
and then you have the kind of Bayesian
implementations of
active inference.
It's an interesting question.
You Know whether you think
the brain is actually
Bayesian, you know,
because a lot of psychologists
will tell you that
the brain departs from Bayesian optimal
reasoning almost everywhere.
In almost all and almost always,
you know.
So yeah.
Who the inference.
Welcome back, Dave.
So one of the questions from Dave was
have you looked at functional delusions,
socialized
as in mobs or depth psychological?
No, no, I'm just I'm still on the
I'm still on the standard curriculum of
delusions of misidentification.
Cotard delusions,
schizophrenic, schizophrenic delusions.
I haven't talked about mass psychology
in that psychology.
I have some thoughts.
But I mean, clearly,
like self modeling applies, right?
If you're talking about how ideas
propagate, propagate
in populations,
then I guess you could say
those those ideas
which are most consistent with a self
model,
are going to be more easily absorbed and
they've not stabilized,
you know, within the individual.
So it's going to be very hard
to get traction for an idea
or an ideology that doesn't
fit with a self model
and probably self models
since they're constructed to
regulate affective states.
That tells you that the ideas
which propagate
and stabilize are going to be those which
get traction with people's affective
self model.
You know what?
That make them feel a certain way rather
than a kind of intellectual argument.
You're not going to persuade
an anti-vaxxer by giving them statistics,
and you're not going to get a kind
of propagation, a wave of something
across social media on the basis of,
you know, an irrational inference.
But that's I don't have anything
super much to say about that.
Very true that we see
sharing and activation patterns
in the sort of global brain
based upon affect not veracity
or accuracy or and yet feature.
And maybe that speaks to another one
of Dave's questions, which was
how your work illuminate the notion
of cognitive dissonance or consonance.
Even in his technical work, Leon Festinger
seems not to succeed in building
a credible dynamics of compatibility
and incompatibility among psychic atoms.
Relevant passages of Gregory
Watson's essays
in steps towards an ecology of Mind
seems similarly limited.
So whether or not you've read
those specific texts.
I have written specific things,
but I suppose one way of thinking of it
is within the kind of active
inference or within the
predictive processing framework is
if you get some discrepant
information that
contradicts or contradicts or self model
or contradicts a predictive model,
you have some choices.
You can revise the model.
That's the perceptual inference to say,
or you can explore the world
and try and get some
you get some further information
to confirm your model
that that seems to be
the active inference approach.
And obviously life is a balance, right?
Life is a balance between the two.
Keep your model
or get some more information.
But it seems like if you
if we take the scientific
analogy of hypothetical inference, often
what people do with discrepant inference
in sort of discrepant
information is just compartmentalize it.
They just put it away.
And scientists have science, you know,
knowing that through it, no one throws
out a good scientific theory
just because of some discrepant evidence,
even if that can't be reconciled.
You know, right now no one's
checking out the theory of evolution
because someone came up
with a wacky organism or wacky function.
You know, it's like they must
there's got to be some explanation.
I don't know what it is,
but let's just we'll just doing our thing
and hope that eventually
it'll be realized, you know.
So I don't think people
is these ideas of kind of
updating or upgrading hypotheses in
the face of the flux of new information.
That's actually not true
because we can't be that sensitive
to information that would be mad.
Right.
So and I guess if you have a self model
that's getting around the world
and functioning,
you know, if your religion,
if you are highly religious person
or something like that
and you live in a religious community
and you go to college and, you know,
Ray Dawkins or something like that, well,
I mean, you have a choice.
You can throw out your whole self,
modeling your whole worldview.
Or you might
just think, like many surgeons,
scientists and otherwise rational people
like I, this is my life in the hospital
where I'm a neuroscientist or whatever.
And this is my life at home
where I'm a preacher and a family
patriarch of a religious community
because complete consistency
across all the levels
and all the functions
is too much.
But I would say because it threatens a
kind of self model, it's not because it's
you know,
that kind of compartmentalization
is not so much
a matter of intellectual consistency,
so much as consistency
with the self model.
And very importantly that the self model
includes the sensory evidence
and that meta model.
So even though my background
is in evolutionary biology
very early,
I realized that people who believe
in evolution, people who believe
in creation, every other flavor
look at tree
and see evidence for their world model.
So that's the starting point
for the discussion,
not that you see the evidence,
but that everybody sees evidence
confirming their view.
And that's a very different discussion
than the dogma tests.
Who might be on any side?
Not a side. Right. And yes.
And no one is going to come.
No one's going to come to the top.
No one's going to come to the topic
with no model
that's going to say,
put aside your preconceptions.
Well, there's no such thing.
But so yeah. Yes definitely.
And that is relevant
for the cognitive bias
and bias discussion
in these future systems.
Or we'll have an unbiased system.
What is that even going to mean?
Yeah, exactly.
And that is, you know, the strength
weakness of the Bayesian thing, isn't it?
Because the Bayesian ideas,
you know, start ab initio
and then you get some evidence
and you update your model,
you get more evidence
and you update your model
that's on,
but you've got to start from somewhere.
And so much of the action in Bayesian
theory is in the Prius,
but there's no theory internal to base
which will tell you where your prior
assumptions about much weight
to give incoming
evidence is going to come from it.
It's a little bit more like blockchain
with the way
that we can make our priors explicit.
You don't step around this issue
by using frequentist statistics
or by casting t ruts,
so at least we can have a discussion.
Hey, I use different priors,
but for an answer versus
we use radically different families
of priors and hyper priors
and we're converging on a similar action.
So maybe that speaks to at least
this action being appropriate,
if not it being the old.
Yeah, that's a yeah,
that's a very good point.
It's not as though yeah.
It's not as though
anyone else has a solution to,
to where do we start from, you know,
what are our foundation,
what are our foundational assumptions.
Yeah.
So it's a bit rude to criticize,
but Bayesian is for saying
that there has to be a
lot of action in the priors.
Right, though
there has to be a lot of information
in the prize to get the off the ground.
True.
But you know, that's an assignment
anyone get from Skins or anyone.
They just.
Yeah, exactly.
So what other
phrase or piece that came to mind
was almost like parametric hysteresis.
The idea that although most sensory
evidence is sort of just off,
kind of like Teflon on our mind,
you look away, it's just totally gone.
There are traumatic experiences.
And then on the other side,
there are healing modalities,
whether it's a healing experience
or a biochemical intervention, right?
There's interventions that restructure
are models and we can think about that,
an active inference perspective.
So I just wondered like philosophically
or from any view,
how do we think these kinds
of changing events, whether kind of
changing in a negative way, like a trauma
or in a positive way, like healing,
how do we scaffold for that?
Well,
that is actually a really good question
because, you know, in this
in the case of psychiatry, it seems like
almost all therapies are equally
and equally bad.
No, none of them really
none of them really work in a way
that we can kind of predict or explain.
That's only statistical
you know, statistical correlations.
So people took their antidepressants
and, you know, so in proportion
get better, but then they relapse.
Some people went to a therapist
or cognitive CBT,
some get better
and some relapse, you know.
So what kind of what kind of
interventions work is really interesting
in the kind of restructuring, you know,
and that's the
that's part of the motivation,
I think for psychedelic approaches
to psychiatry, we're like, okay,
one for my look, I can't really, can't
really have a successful intervention
because that would require
you to rebuild or remodel
yourself.
It's not just changing a perception
and changing our experience.
It's the way you incorporate that in
your whole kind of regulatory framework.
How are we going to do that?
Well, maybe with ten years of therapy,
you know, lots of patient
reconstruction or, well,
sometimes a life changing event.
People give up drugs
because, you know, for
some reason it's a life changing event
or they just grow out of it.
People say that it's hard.
It's hard to have to systematize
that, isn't it?
That was psychedelics.
What people are saying
is, well, let's disrupt this self model.
Let's kind of for a while, let's
introduce maximum entropy into the system
again, you know,
so that they experience life
briefly, hopefully safely
with a lot of their
self model disintegrated
yet. And so they get to see
life for once unfiltered in a normally
everything is filtered.
How does this matter to me in relation
to me in relation to my history, my plans
you know that people admitted
matter to me all of life is
just being filtered
at every level like that
and that's very hard to use
to experience life without that filter.
And psychedelics give you a
a brief, immersive, very destabilizing
experience of life unfiltered
and maybe from that can be a starting
point for something that's good.
Classic William Blake Doors of Perception
idea, and also the REBUS work
by Friston and
and Carhart-Harris as well as this offer
on and actually asking like
maybe there are certain aspects
that these neurochemical interventions
may strengthen.
Maybe it's not just this across the board
weakening of our world,
but there are certain levels of analysis
in which things might be strengthened.
And. Right, right.
On this note of the treatment
and the recovery,
one of the very early slides,
I think it was Mr.
A was the patient.
And then right came in initially
presenting
some phenotypes
and then there was plasma.
And instead after a few plasma exchanges,
you know,
he had improved
and then he had this other thing.
And so I thought
interesting treatments.
What does it say about the body
and the brain or what made
these doctors go for the plasma exchange?
And was it with with the white matter?
Right.
Well, because
because they had this idea that
they had
they had this
they had this idea that inflammation,
you know, was the core
of a lot of these catastrophic
the core of a lot of the symptoms.
And when you when you look at depression
and you look at psychiatric disorders,
people often get wrapped up
in the sensory experience and the
and the cognitive experience.
You know,
people say things that are so crazy,
you know, and the thing is,
why would you say that?
Why are they so irrational?
You know, and people start at that level
and they talk to them and they say,
try and understand their life experience
and all this or whatever.
But the view of these guys in Mexico is,
look, look, look at the other symptoms
look what's happening.
You know, the guy pissing
his pants is shitting himself,
hasn't been to sleep for three days
and then he sleeps for two weeks
and he doesn't want to eat anything,
hasn't eaten for a week, you know.
So this is like really basic.
It's really basic.
Functioning is out of control now
and that looks like it.
Maybe that's a kind of
and we know that, you know, inflammation
does affect homeostasis
this really badly.
And so that was they thought,
you know, let's
and then let's test them for all these,
you know,
antibodies for encephalitis
and they find it so plasma
exchange is the treatment for that.
And then, of course,
you might think, oh, well,
all right, but up
that's not something
you're going to repair straight away.
When you when you've gone
from homeostatic catastrophe
to a bit of reintegration,
you know,
you're still going to be left with
the cognitive level
has to get back in touch with you know
if you're thinking
of those kind of levels of organization
and systematic
functioning and interaction.
Well okay
you change the molecular level function.
You don't change everything
straight away, which is why
it's very nice study by Catherine Harmer.
You know, give people antidepressants
or anything
like I give people antidepressants
or you've changed their serotonin levels
within an hour, I'd say you report
their serotonin level across the brain
back to now why that why it's if if that
if the serotonin
theory of anti-depression is right,
don't they feel better?
They change their pattern of thinking.
It does affect
it does affect some very kind of low
level perceptual processing, though.
So their patterns of gaze
depressive people
that cycads are very avoidant.
You know if you show them emotional faces
or something they don't look at the
the nose, the eyes,
the mouth, the eyes automatically avert
people with anxiety and so on.
So they're not getting any positive,
you know, emotional feedback
from their social world.
But if you give people antidepressants,
that pattern of seconds
changes within a few hours.
So it's almost like you're giving them
the ability
now to do some active inference
and reacquire some
some some new information
about about their world.
So If they go around the world, luckily,
and they people smile at them
and laugh and talk with them, then
they're getting some new information.
But that's not going to disrupt
straightaway all the high level
models that they've built
to them.
You know, you're not going to change
that.
That's not going to happen straight away.
And that story
about, the serotonin story
I've personally felt,
is that disciplinary hierarchy, it's
like, well, we know how this drug works.
Look at my simulation of how it binds
the receptors you bring up.
But then if it did that and that's simply
how it worked, if it weren't just,
you know,
changing a complex biological system
that wouldn't a time
course of action be very different.
And it's a it's a looking
where the light is
because we can make these simulations
with a docking of a molecule,
but as yet we lack
some of these layers in between.
Absolutely.
The vibrating molecule
and our phenomenology,
which is sort of that fog of experience
that we're exploring together.
Yeah, no, I absolutely 100% agree.
And I think
again, but most of my practicing
psychiatrist, colleagues
and collaborators, they would agree too.
But there's a big
industrial complex, you know, that has
that has an interest in thinking,
you know, persuading people otherwise.
And also people are desperate.
Yeah, yeah.
Can't wait till we have big Pryor
and big precision.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
You brought up the Australian philosopher
Colin Klein, who
I was familiar with
because of the collaboration with Andy
Baron, actually, about basil experience
in honeybees and in insects.
So it just was an interesting connection
with thinking about, okay,
if we're going to take this sort of
bottom up computational approach,
then where we take that in
not just the clinic
but in the evolutionary context.
Yeah, he's a great
he's a great force for sure.
And he's really got his
finger on the pulse of all,
I think that cross-disciplinary
the material that you need to do that
kind of thing.
Well, he's really good like that.
Here's another just in these last
few minutes, a question from the chat
he wrote.
Any thoughts about the role of nonsense,
haptic information
transmission across the brain,
especially at static coupling?
Thank you kindly.
Honestly, I don't really know
that.
I don't as
clearly it's
got to have there's no reason
within, say, active inference framework
or actually any computational
to think that, you know,
the fundamental mechanism
has to be synaptic,
although it could it could be anything.
Right.
How the brain is organizing
the body
to get through the world to survive
could be anything could help itself
to any mechanism, you know,
astrocytes, glial cells,
whatever the hell, you know.
But we have got we bought into
this idea that it's synaptic
probably going back
to Hebb and people like that
and neural network theory
is that it's a synaptic theory
of these units,
interconnected units with weights
which are supposed to model
some abstract level synaptic functioning.
Right.
We might be off
we might be off of track there,
but so
maybe this is a kind of a good advantage,
good advantage of active inference.
It's like at the moment, computational
theory is hung up with a synthetic model
because that's what deep learning
and neural networks are.
Right setting of sitting awaits
across the brain.
But that's a very abstract idea of
and you know, it's a very abstract idea
of what it was on it was on about.
And most neuroscientists,
like I had a guy talk in my class
the other day, invited him
to give a lecture.
He works on Dragonfly Vision
and he was just talking about the neurons
in the eyes of dragonflies.
You're saying there is all this stuff
in there that we don't know?
Glial cells, astrocytes.
What the hell is that?
What they're doing?
They're encoding other encoding it.
But he says if
you mess with their function,
then you
mess with the ability
of the dragonflies to
to do their incredibly accurate flying
and landing and sensory representations.
So yeah, so maybe the synthetic model is
once it's a case of looking
where the light is, you know,
artificial neural networks, they're great
and they can do a lot of things,
but they are kind of level abstraction.
Then again, Bayesian models
are an even higher level abstraction
if you if you want to put it that way,
because the Bayesian model, the Bayesian
models say, okay, you've got a system
interacting with its environment.
And I've got a function,
a function that tells you
how the system's going to interact
with its environment.
And I can devolve that into a loop of,
if you like, I can devolve
that into a lot of subsidiary
levels of a Bayesian
Bayesian inference all the way down.
But how do they want how do they
how do they glom onto
the actual molecular soup?
I don't know.
But I mean, that's the
that's the job of it, isn't it? Yeah.
That's that's why I guess still
dopaminergic
functioning in the brain
is still a bit of a triumph because
sorry, understanding the document system,
because you have
a system whose properties
map pretty
well the predictions of formal theory
you know, of temple difference
learning and reward learning
not perfectly, but you know it does fit.
So that's good. So that's good.
That's good.
And the same does seem to say
we're in the ballpark.
Matteo.
Guillermo has a paper on the dopamine
signaling about explanatory
from a philosophical perspective
about the way in which the dopaminergic
signaling in in different ways
can be seen as consistent
with precision account,
the reward account or other accounts.
And so it's like maybe let's
wait a few decades.
Yeah.
Before we,
you know, give out the trophies.
Let's yeah, yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
So I'll just very good because.
That's right why can it nascent
friston have a paper on that
even you know and actually there are
a couple of good papers on that now.
Yeah, it would be within the active
inference framework
we can conceptualize that
the domain system
as you know fine tuning fine
tuning patterns of active inference
rather than back
propagating a reward signal.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So I'll just close with this sort
of this diptych of questions,
a little high road in a low road,
one of the paths would be
what research directions do you think
are exciting for people to pursue?
And the other side is
how do you think for non researchers
what you've spoken to today
might change the way
that they think or act?
I think for researchers,
I think I think any researcher
should still keep researching
what they're interested in.
Like if you've got a fascination
or an interest in Dragonfly vision,
dopaminergic signaling, whatever,
I think you should just keep going for it
and incorporate
active inference or any framework
that that is, is, is helping.
You know,
I don't think jumping on the bandwagon
for any research is helpful, although
you've got to bear
in mind that if you're trying to function
in an institutional environment,
you're going to be on some bandwagon,
you're going to be in some lab,
some in a school of thought.
But I think it still should get
still got to do what you're interested
in rather than promote,
you know, someone else's program.
So I don't have a kind of
I would love to see
I would love to see that
that kind
of bristolian ideas
and everything could be
put in a intuitive way
that made them more accessible
for people who are looking for a kind
of a kind of recipe offs or something
like that, because they're so technical
and they're so formal
and it's hard to extract
how to extract the gold, you know,
if you know what I mean.
And that's why. Yeah.
So I think it's a good suite of examples
would be really helpful.
But you know, standard cases
that people use to explain it
would be good.
You know, just as often these examples,
the examples are wrong, right?
So you think of Mars theory,
vision, okay, probably wrong.
But at least
it kind of gave you a way to understand,
you know,
what's going on in the visual system.
And then you can fine tune
it and change it and argue with it
and everything like that.
But he gave people a way
of taking the understanding
of perception out of this, out of
out of a really kind of technical
specialized framework.
And now philosophers
talk about it, psychologists, everyone.
And it's probably become a little bit
of an albatross around the neck of
the picture, but no one's come up with
no one's come up with it like a good one.
It would be nice if someone could
mean that because the Maas
framework is so, so, so
clear on it and and it works for active
inference too.
You can say, well, look,
the mind is in the business sense
about how he says of re
reconstructing
the causal structure of the world,
you know, inferring the causal structure
of the world
outside, beyond its boundaries.
So it's very internalized view, but
that's a very plausible way of doing it.
Yeah, I get it.
You know, you can explain it to students
and to people.
Look, the brain is stuck inside its skull
it can't it can engage with the world.
It can only ever do it
by proxy indirectly.
And what does it have?
Photons, sensory receptors.
It's got to build a picture.
And, you know,
that's what maps it and how you put it
in the predictive processing framework.
Something like that would be helpful
to get that idea across.
You can do it for other modalities,
of course, contraception, know whatever.
Sorry.
What what was the other question.
Though on the non research
frontier is just in the day to day,
how is this influence
how we might think or act
just in our day to day experiences?
I think it makes a big difference
if you think of yourself
as you think of your behavior
as confirming a moral,
you know, I think it makes a really,
really big difference.
You know, if you're arguing
like you're arguing with your partner or,
you know, stuck in
a way of life or visiting
especially especially social interaction.
And think of social interaction
as you know, I've got a thought.
I'm going to try and get a point across
or I've got a goal.
I to equate the goal, but
I want to make friends with this person.
I want to do this, I want to do that,
and then you can get pissed off
or whatever you do if it's working not.
But maybe the right way to think of it
is, you know,
I've got a model
of how I function in the world
and my brain has built this picture
of how I function in the world.
And I'm just now
I'm bungling around the world
trying to optimize it, you know?
So what I think what I think of
as this kind of, you know,
autonomous engagement of this,
you know, individual who is above it all
and choosing and whatever and, you know,
making decisions and
not really maybe what I'm doing
is bungling around the world, trying
to optimize my model and maybe I've got
I can get stuck in a local minima, right?
I can get stuck in a, you know,
all my models, my model is not working.
We had this discussion
maybe I don't know if you know,
this philosopher Dominic
Murphy is a fantastic philosopher of
science and psychology
that we have to think of,
you know, this notion.
But a lot of the time
what you're doing is brand management
yourself, that you are
is this model that you made that works
for you in your environment, your family,
as you're growing up or high school
or whatever, like this.
And you've got this brand now,
and unfortunately or fortunately,
that's how other people see
your actions are really about
getting a brand out
there, brand brand management.
And if you identify
with your brand right, you know,
but if the brand
if your brand isn't working for you
and if you and
if you just see your actions as, oh, God,
I am just what I'm doing, it's
kind of finessing and sort of
and reinforcing and fortifying this model
of how I act in the world.
Does it have to be like that?
You know, oh.
Very nice point
that instead of social interactions
maximizing my reward, reward
or shared reward zero sum,
we can actually think about
what if we were both
reducing our uncertainty
about a positive social interaction
and what might be known as win
win in the reward paradigm?
But here.
Yeah, that's a really good way.
That's a really good way to think of it.
That's a really good way.
Yeah, exactly.
Thank you for this awesome visit.
It was really a fascinating talk
and one of in the chat.
Brilliant practical advice.
Thanks, Daniel,
and thanks for your guest.
So yeah, thanks.
Thanks a lot from our lab
and you and anyone else
are always welcome to join anytime.
Thank you very much.
Has a really great experience.
Nice to try.
These ideas out in this discussion was
really helpful and informed, you know.
So thank you very much for the chance.
And I'll be propagating you know,
I'll be spreading the news about the lab.
So thank you. Thanks a lot.
Thanks a lot.
By the way, everyone, by
nice talk.
Pretty cool.